[Music]
soccer now and after a year-long delay
because of the pandemic the postponed
euro 2020
is finally kicking off the tournament
starts tonight
in rome with italy taking on turkey
kickoff is less than three hours away
but for the first time in its history
the event will be taking place across
europe
despite the pandemic all 11 host cities
have been
clear been cleared to have fans in the
stadiums but for those without a ticket
host cities have set up fan zones where
people can watch the games on giant
screens
lima hataki from dw sports joins us now
from one of those fan zones
at rome's piazza del popolo the people's
square
eliminates not long to go there now
before kickoff and you're right in the
heart of the city what's the atmosphere
like
[Music]
the euro 2020 atmosphere is everywhere
and
nowhere it's a very strange paradox you
could be walking
the streets of rome and not even realize
that the opener to one of the biggest
football tournaments in the world
is about to kick off in a few hours time
we saw very little flags
hanging from rooftops from homes from
balconies
then of course on the other hand you
have clusters such as these and i have
to show them to you you have to see this
this year for example is one of three
public screenings organized by uefa
and up to 1 000 fans will be expected to
be
here of course they have to follow very
very strict guidelines they have to wear
masks
and keep a distance and what's so
interesting is that a lot of the locals
that we spoke to
we're not even aware if public
screenings are happening at
all and that's because uefa initially
had said
that due to the covet due to covet 19
they would not hold these sort of events
so
a lot of locals found out yesterday only
a few days ahead of time
and also through word of mouth but going
back to your question about the
atmosphere the football atmosphere
for italian standards i would say it's
quite mellow but perhaps maybe you know
as the tournament picks up and they
start winning games
and i do believe that the italian
football spirit will
slowly come back that is quite
surprising to hear that about the
dampened spirit uh
no doubt of course the coronavirus has a
lot to
a big role to play in that have fans in
rome expressed
any concerns
it's a mixed bag rebecca i mean it
depends who you talk to you get a
gazillion different answers um
on the one hand of course being able to
host a tournament like this of this
magnitude
the opener i'm talking about the opening
event does bring
back a sense of normalcy for a lot of
locals here
but on the other hand and of course you
also have the economic boost that also
you know injects money into the economy
but on the other hand
it's a risky business we should not
forget that italy was the epicenter
in europe of the coronavirus pandemic
and i spoke to a lot of
locals and many here are concerned that
events like this could perhaps lead
to a search of covet 19 cases
well we hope not fingers crossed there
now lima we're really running out of
time but just looking ahead to the match
itself
can the home country italy be confident
of a win tonight
hey they have momentum they're unbeaten
in 27 games
although this tournament will be a big
test but they do have a beautiful
home advantage well i've picked them in
the tipping so
fingers crossed they're eliminated in
rome for dw sports thank you
and in other football news brazil's
supreme court has ruled the nation can
host the copa america
set to start this sunday after days of
doubt had
that the torment tournament's future was
in limbo the vote to hold the copa was
unanimous despite political groups
challenging the tournament because of a
surge in coronavirus cases
resistance even came from the brazilian
national team
it was originally due to be hosted by
colombia and argentina before those two
countries were dropped
the copa is to take place without fans
in stadiums
you